[Music]
welcome to every damn day today we're
talking about why Nicolas Cage is
clearly an alien and to do that first
you got to watch this great ok so this
clip comes to us from vampires kiss Ryan
you want to tell us where this is
happening in the movie go to your right
yeah so in the vampire's kiss Nic Cage
is at no point of vampire that's what
makes this even crazier yeah yeah he
just thinks he's a vampire cuz he takes
this girl home and he thinks that she's
been he's been bitten by her and then he
goes kind of crazy and he bites somebody
else in this club and he scares this
woman that he works with and then she
shoots a gun at him but it's filled with
blanks cuz she's scared of bullets and
so then he thinks he's invincible and
then he runs down the street like that
if you were like hey my task is to
convey that I have been transformed into
a vampire choice me just to run down the
street and over and over yell I'm a
vampire how do you not know for sure
have you been bitten in that well let's
find out here are five reasons why
Nicolas Cage is an alien reason one
crazy-rich Cajun this man bought a
private island a dinosaur skull and on
top of that he also bought shrunken
pygmy heads clearly used for some sort
of like alien purposes what's like the
weirdest thing as of now that you have
purchased I like hype myself up to buy
like a theremin for like months you know
if they're minute it's like instrument
where you play the air and then it like
creates like I'm from there like a sort
of aliens yeah
[Music]
every practice daughter gets and I like
played it like twice and then I was like
what so expensive my brother owns a
theremin yeah and he's also a enormous
Nick Cage fan it's possible that my
brother might be an alien as Jordan I
think all people on our set I think
Jordan is most likely to be an alien I
don't know so private island normal or
normal rich guy alien rich guy
supervillain doesn't ring a lien to me
okay how about a haunted mansion he
bought a New Orleans haunted mansion
[Applause]
how about shrunken pygmy heads a little
creepy weirdo creep creep yep that's
weird
I only want to do with the shrunken head
they probably have uses for all kinds of
sizes that's fine
reason number two okay let's play this
clip of Nicolas Cage playing an Italian
mandolin player if I do that I'll start
getting confused about when I'm supposed
to come in and that in a concert hall
would be a disaster okay he is related
to Italian this to me sounds like if an
alien was tasked with infiltrating in
Italy I don't know why he's talking like
this it's almost like a French person
but he is speaking it like I'm supposed
to be Italian he is so Italian this is I
mean maybe he's not maybe maybe he's an
alien to me it sounds like if he was
trying to combine Mario Brothers with
Andrea Bocelli it's so French
I mean Italian I grew up don't sound
like that they said when ia ate it was
up Kurt how you doing I don't think
that's right either
so for the attack don't say what's up
cuz how you doing that's our food dude
would you want a piece of bro oh all
right that's awfully that's an Italian
accent yes
now I think you see the world and it's
just a bunch of Chris cotton he's also
fat
alright we're kind of getting more
convinced on I feel like I'm getting you
on board reason 3 Nicholas Cage named
his son kal-el after Superman's birth
name and Superman by the way say with me
I mean that's just silly
can't we just go back to like you know
John and David and Ralph anyone named
Ralph
I'll just go why would I
I don't want to know someone named
kal-el you know I'm gonna know someone
named Kyle out because I'm an income
best friends with that kid oh my god
he's gonna be so rich we're gonna go to
good dinners yeah your YouTube your next
YouTube challenge rich is gonna be
really easy to manipulate and then 20
years later will actually become
actually really good friends and then
he'll find this YouTube clip and he'll
be like what this whole thing was a
challenge this hold and then I'm gonna
like it started out it's a challenge but
it really means everything to me you're
my best friend and then Nic Cage will
star in the movie as reason for nouveau
sham maniac is Nicolas Cage's
self-developed acting style inspired by
shamans so he behaves the way shamans
behaved when they were in villages
solving like the problems of their
village and that's how he Boy alien
you're currently internet I'm an acting
class right now and I found out that I
am so bad at acting it's actually like
nuts and I feel like badly for everyone
else like watch me act so like like what
you can do on our sketch show
I'm gonna click on over to that next
everyday I'm sketching though go ahead
and step let us know if you think
Jordans a good actor really email me my
email is Jourdan dot dot mendoza at
gmail.com that's my personal email and
any password is the point is that I
think it's are so hard to be acting that
like being shamanic that's a cool I'm
gonna try that tomorrow in two days
means nothing what do you mean you're
gonna try it you don't act you feel you
imagine a new channel okay with a great
assault so let's see it in action so
this is fresh this does feel like some
sort of shamanic
this is really good compared to me yeah
this is from Nicolas Cage loses his
super popular YouTube video please check
it out you're gonna love it
I also just want to take a second to
just say the ladies in those clips we
acknowledge you there's so many women
who act alongside Nick just stare at him
while he does all that you just see it
behind their eyes all of a sudden it
clicks and it's like okay this is gonna
be a clip that will be laughed at and
they're like classically trained there's
a Meisner and Stanislavski and all these
things and he's like just Romanies Nic
Cage of thongs where they watch all the
movies and then they get and while they
get drunk and laugh at how crazy is and
then they walk to the movie theater and
watch the new one that comes out at
midnight like their own ritual around
this guy you can I mean just go to
Missouri and you'll be able to check it
out man well to add to our arsenal
before we watch the latest Nic Cage
movie Mandy right which is in theaters
right now here so good here so good -
all right so reason 5 so this is Nicolas
Cage's diet alright he these animals who
have sex in a way that he deems as
dignified oh my god I got a question for
you farts what animal do you have sex
like which animal comes the fastest
basically they come they come slow but
in there it's like not a lot of pumps so
they put it a couple with it
everywhere I don't think that's right
like but it's like if but if you spit up
it's like real time it'd be like hey you
know what they say when they come
they're like what up cuz
[Laughter]
crazy guy he's not my kosher or halal
meat he's talking about the way they
have sex you know that's a weird thing
to goo how the vid the Vil let me see
how do you have that's the way they do
he doesn't eat pigs and so then I
immediately went to the internet and
watched a lot of pigs have sex and Fred
research pretty normal yeah it works for
research yes and I think bros
[Music]
sure Conair is about an airplane full of
convicts but isn't it really about how
prisoners get a ton of legroom there are
so many good reasons researching this I
just couldn't help myself I wanted to
include one more so Dre throw up that
headline Nicolas Cage's also bought
himself a nine-foot to be buried in New
Orleans so it's pre haunted it's a
haunted tomb
so now you've heard everything let's go
around the horn yes or no isn't it Cajun
alien Jordan no he's not he's just a
cool guy ended with Jordan Chris do you
believe aliens 18 yep that boy UT I'm
going to go alien stamp it alright now
you tell us in the comments is he an
alien and why or why not
is he et you tell us and now Ryan I
believe you have a shadow for us why yes
I do Natasha tomorrow are the midterm
elections no matter where you live you
have a chance to vote for local state
and Congress and no matter what your
political party there's one thing we can
all agree on we all hate Congress so if
you're asking yourself hashtags should I
vote the answer is hell yes you should
what is wrong with you so go to CC comm
slash vote check out where and when to
vote and we all tell you who to vote for
but you know and go vote that's our
episode make sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and boats
[Music]